well it is friday night maybe the next
time you pour yourself a nice glass of
wine remember the next one may be a
little bit harder to come by as another
industry now taking a huge hit during
the pandemic because of supply chain
issues victoria saha joins us now in
studio with a look at what this could
mean the next time you pull the cork
victoria
yeah nationwide wine bottles and
aluminum cans are gold right now for
wine and beer producers as they're
becoming harder to come by it's a
challenge the industry wasn't expecting
to face
a shortage of glass bottles is something
to whine about right now we were just
panicking a little bit and just
scrambling everywhere nicole sharp the
director of marketing for vegas valley
winery says they just got their shipment
of 8 thousand wine bottles in an order
that was placed back in june in addition
to just being short on bottle supplies
the cost of bottles have more than
doubled in a year and a half this is
their newest shred it's a petite
verdeaux and usually this bottle would
go for 36 dollars but the price increase
of the supplies is causing it to go up
to 38 dollars a bottle sharp says she's
hoping the price increase doesn't pour
over to the other wines wine could go to
waste if it stays in the barrels for too
long without being bottled and corked
over at craft house brewery aluminum
cans are also part of the supply chain
issue within the industry it's called
the candemic
owner wendy forrest says not only are
they competing with local breweries for
cans but big companies like coca-cola we
have to plan
really far ahead craft house just got a
shipment in from california the cans
alone cost three thousand dollars they
also have to pay for shipping which is
usually around three hundred dollars
this week it cost them thirty two
hundred we can't do a direct increase
because there's other options and people
would choose the lower priced options
forest predicts it will take them seven
years to bounce back to pre-pandemic
prices as for wine bottles it might
sound like a better option to reuse them
but wineries need to follow a specific
fda guidelines meaning they have to go
through a glass recycling company where
they are crushed and repurposed denise
all right victor